no one wants to wait for a guy to get
ready or like if you're ever taking a
blow dryer to your hair get it out Wow
get out I love something I can like hold
on to interesting rattling my mom likes
ponytails I found I really don't like
long hair I don't like the Fabio hair
thing as long as his hair is shorter
than mine it's fine my first crush was
on um the Beast and Beauty and the Beast
when he transformed back into a man and
he like kind of looks like Axl Rose's
premies liquids too feminine or
something for me I don't know I like
like feminine I want like my lumberjack
yeah yeah give me my ass like a man but
I am very much into a man but right now
I'm not out here looking for dudes and
man buns that's not oh that's not my
true man bun no thank you
why he's didn't know man butter and I
saw the hair tie in the bathroom and I
at first I thought it was another girl
my ex had long hair and the growing out
process I hated it he looked like a
lesbian but after he was able to put it
in a ponytail or a man bun oh man I was
like town that is hot like that was sexy
I do not want a guy with corn rolls oh
hell no no you braid it or you go to
your mom's house to Braden
know or your homeboys brain oh one room
or you're asking me to braid and no no
we can have like writing sessions and
you know doesn't lie in bed all night
and just chat and colorants like I like
I like bald guys marsh chestnut balls
like the milk dud shiny all bald is one
thing like if it's like a shaved Bend
diesel look I don't know maybe a
deal-breaker hairstyle a mullet so you
don't like mullets
I don't like mullets but it's like a
specific weird euro football player
Molly I know exactly what you're talking
about
definitely mind it white guy drips
that's stopping just just oh I don't
like when it when you need to use a lot
of product you shouldn't love your
products more than I love my products
also here that's too hard like dues that
for too much killing it yeah and you're
like why like just let it kind of just
do what it wants to do crunchy crunchy
oh that's even more like the wet look
that that isn't wet like Stamos when his
hair wasn't fluffy anymore so they were
like I guess we'll gel it